رئيس السلام عليكم
اعصرنا انكم مجددا في جمهوريه كوريا وان
نلتقي بفخامتكم ويطيب لنا ننقل تحيات سيدي
خالد الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز حفظه الله وتمنياته لحكمتكم وللشعب
الكوري صديق المزيد من التقدم والرقي
ويطيب لنا نتقدم بشكر الجزيره على الدعوه
الكريمه وعلى ما لقيناه من الحفاوه
استقبال وكرام ضيافه تاتي هذه الزياره
لبلادكم مرور 60 عاما على انشاء
العلاقات بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وجمهوريه مما يؤكد رغبه بلدينا في
الاستمرار في ترسيخ اسس هذه العلاقه
التاريخيه والعمل على استكمال الجهود
الراميه الى تعزيز التعاون في جميع
المجالات واخذهم في الاعتبار ما يتركز
عليه بلدين الصديقين من الثقل سياسي
واقتصادي واقليمي ودولي وعضويه البلدينا
في مجموعه 20 فاننا نسعى لتكثيف العمل
المشترك للمواجهه كل ويهدد الامن والسلم
الدوليين وياثر على الامن الطاقه وسلامه
سلاسل
لقد شهدت العلاقه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا تطورا كبيره خلال
العقود السته الماضيه نتج عنها شراكه
استراتيجيه مثمره للبلدين ومن اجل
المحافظه على مكتسبات هذه العلاقه فاننا
حرصنا دائما على تكثيف التشاور والتنسيق
مع بلدكم الصديق بما يحقق الطلعه
الاقتصاديه الطموحه وبناء مستقبل افضل
المنطقه والعالم خاصه في ظل التحديات
الكبيره يشهدها عالمنا اليوم وفي هذا
الصدد مشير الى التعاون وثيق اطار الرؤيه
السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 ونشيد بما تم
خلالها كما نتابع باهتمام كبير ومنجزات
اللجان المشتركه بين بلدينا ولطلع يرفع
وتيره التنسيق الاستثماري وتعزيز الشراكه
بينقطاعين العامه الخاص ونؤكد على اهميه
الاستفاده من فرص التجاريه واستثماريه
الواعده والمتاحه للتعاون بين بلدينا
ونشيد في هذا السياق بالنمو الايجابي في
السنوات الماضيه المعادلات التبادل
التجاري بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وكوريا
وتقديرا فخامتكم على حرص على حرصكم
بالعلاقه بالبلدين شكرا